好きですか?この抑揚というか?
いや、全部きれいで。
ご家族では英語でしゃべる?
日本語ですよね。
私の娘がね、やっぱりお家では日本語で、そうじゃないと日本語を例えば大学で取りますよね。
それでもこういう普通の日本語って習わないから、しゃべれるようにならないから。
だからお家では日本語をしゃべる。
みんなそう知ってたはずなのね。私の妹が一人いるんだけど、旦那さんがイギリス人なんですね。
それでやっぱり女の子がいて、お家では日本語って言ってたんだけど、エミの日本語変ですよね。
本当に、あの、すごい。
え、言うのも言うの?
うん。もう何年もでも10年くらいあってない。
うん。今だけどもうね。お家にいないから。
あの、ボストンでやってた。
うん、ボストン。
そう。今ね、バイティが、えっと、きって、びっくりしたことが、うん。
しましたから、私はあなたはどういう音楽、うん。
好きな音楽を教えてください。
エスペイン語だった。
エスペイン語の音楽。
エスペイン語で。
タイキ?
タイキが日本語一番上手よね。書けるんで、それこそ私より書けるのよ。
書けるの。
カイキに弾けるの。
本当。
でも、わからないですよね。
全然わかんないですよね。これだけしゃべれてると、その紙書いっていうのよくわかんないですよね。
うん。
だって日本語ってやっぱり、読みかけが大変だから。
アンビカとドアアルです。
アメリカでスペイン語が載せる。
ドッキュセイガ。
うーん。
あの、大輝のね。
うん。
ピックにしました。
アンビちゃんと喧嘩するときは英語なんですよ。
ああ、うん。
アンビちゃんと喧嘩するの。
そうそう。
そうなんだ。
考えてみればそうだね。
感情が高ぶったときに出るのは英語なんですかね。
うーん。
なんでかな。
でも、私はね。
それぐらいできるようになると言うけど、
アメリカのネットシンに行きました。
いや、うん。
で、こういう印象がアメリカヒートが、
例えば私は、ラティノ、スペイン語が話せる人が、
集まって、何よりも楽しみ。
わいわいわいわなんとか楽しみ。
アメリカヒートが、